YOU NEVER KNOW.
JILLIAN: YOU NEVER KNOW.
STEVE: MEANWHILE, THE VICE
PRESIDENT, KAMALA HARRIS IS
TAKING ON THE LEAD AS JOE
BIDEN’S BORDER BOSS ESSENTIALLY
JUST DAYS AFTER LAUGHING IN THE
FACE OF A REPORTER WHO PRESSED
HER ON WHEN IS SHE GOING GO
LOOK.
>> DO YOU PLAN TO VISIT THE
BORDER?
>> UM, NOT TODAY.
[LAUGHTER]
STEVE: WELL NOW THAT’S NOW HER
BOSS.
JOE BIDEN PASSING THE BUCK, WHAT
CAN WE EXPECT TO HAPPEN AT THE
BORDER?
LET’S TALK TO RETIRED ACTING ICE
DIRECTOR AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR TOM HOMAN.
TOM, GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING.
STEVE: WE KNOW SHE WAS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL FROM THE
SANCTUARY STATE OF CALIFORNIA,
BUT WHAT ELSE DO WE KNOW ABOUT
HOW SHE REGARDS OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER?
>> WELL, WHEN PRESIDENT BIDEN
SAYS SHE IS THE MOST QUALIFIED,
I MEAN, SERIOUSLY?
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, WHAT COLOR IS
THE SKY IN HIS WORLD?
BECAUSE YOU CAN’T GET A WORSE
PICK.
SHE SUPPORTS SANCTUARY CITIES.
WROTE LEGISLATION TO REWARD
THOSE WHO ILLEGALLY ENTER THE
UNITED STATES.
SHE VILIFIED THE MEN AND WOMEN
OF THE BORDER.
SAYING THEY WERE MISTREATING.
SHE WANTS TO ABOLISH ICE.
SHE COMPARED IMMIGRATION
OFFICERS TO THE KKK DURING A
SENATE HEARING.
AND YOU WANT TO PUT HER IN
CHARGE OF IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT ON THE BORDER?
I COULDN’T THINK OF A WORSE
CHOICE.
STEVE: BECAUSE IN 2019 SHE
SUPPORTED DECRIMINALIZING
CROSSING THE BORDER ILLEGALLY.
IT’S A FEDERAL VIOLATION OF
STATUTE AND, YET, SHE WAS SAYING
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THAT SHOULDN’T PROBABLY BE
AGAINST THE LAW.
>> THE MOST QUALIFIED PERSON TO
FIX THIS ISSUE HOW ABOUT THE
CHIEF OF THE UNITED STATES
BORDER PATROL WHO IS A GREAT
GUY.
HE EBB SPENT HIS WHOLE CAREER ON
THE BORDER.
HE COULD FIX IT.
IF YOU GIVE HIM THE POWER TO
CHANGE THE POLICIES THAT NEED TO
BE CHANGED AND LET HIM DO HIS
JOB?
THAT’S THE GUY.
NOT SOME POLITICIAN.
BUT, YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE FIRST
THINGS THEY SAY KAMALA IS GOING
TO DO TROOFL MEXICO AND CENTRAL
AMERICA TO TALK TO THEM FOLKS.
WHY DON’T YOU SIT DOWN AND TALK
TO THE COMMAND OF THE BORDER
PATROL AND THEIR OPINION.
THEY HAVE BEEN THROUGH THIS
BEFORE THEY KNOW HOW TO FIX
THIS.
THE SAME WAY PRESIDENT TRUMP
FIXED IT.
ALL GOT TO TOO ONE THING IF JOE
BIDEN SAID TODAY I’M GOING TO
REESTABLISH REMAIN IN MEXICO
PROGRAM EFFECTIVE IMMEDIATELY,
BORDER CROSSINGS WOULD GO DOWN
75% IN THE 24 HOUR PERIOD.
STEVE: THAT’S A GOOD POINT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT
ENTREPRENEURSHIP, IT WAS ABOUT A
YEAR AGO, HE PUT MIKE PENCE IN
CHARGE OF THE CORONAVIRUS
RESPONSE.
ESSENTIALLY, JOE BIDEN IS
ADMITTING OKAY, THIS IS A CRISIS
SO I’M GOING TO PUT MY NUMBER 2
IN CHARGE OF THIS, BUT THERE IS
POLITICAL PERIL FOR HER BECAUSE
IF IT DOES NOT WORK OUT WELL,
THIS COULD ACTUALLY DAMAGE HER
PRESIDENTIAL AMBITIONS.
>> IT IS NOT GOING TO WORK OUT
WELL.
I WILL TELL YOU THAT RIGHT NOW.
AND JOE BIDEN SHOULD -- YOU
KNOW, LOOK, HE HAS ALREADY SAID
HE WANTS TO HAVE AGREEMENTS WITH
THESE COUNTRIES.
THERE WERE AGREEMENTS ARE
HONDURAS, EL SALVADOR AND
GUATEMALA AND MEXICO THEY
DESTROYED THEM IN TWO WEEKS.
IF THEY WOULD HAVE STUCK TO THE
TRUMP PLAYBOOK JOE BIDEN WOULD
HAVE HAD THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
BORDER SECURITY.
THEY TORE DOWN EVERYTHING TRUMP.
THIS IS WHAT THEY GOT TODAY.
AGAIN, NOT MY ACCIDENT, NOT BY
INCOMPETENCE, BUT BY DESIGN.
THIS IS WHAT OPEN BORDERS LOOKS
LIKE AND JOE BIDEN WIN AN
ELECTION SOLD OUT TO THE
PROGRESSIVE LEFT TO GET AN OPEN
BORDER.
HE KNEW EXACTLY WHAT HE WAS
DOING WHEN HE MADE THESE
PROMISES.
STEVE: BEFORE DID YOU GO I
WANTED TO ASK YOU ABOUT
YESTERDAY THE WHITE HOUSE TOOK A
POOL REPORTER ON A TOUR OF A
FACILITY, I THINK, IN CAN A RAZ
ZOE SPRINGS WHICH IS IT’S ONE OF
THE CHILD FACILITIES, ONE OF THE
CHILD DETENTION FACILITIES.
AND IT’S RUN BY THE DHS.
IT’S NOT RUN BY THE BORDER
PATROL WHICH HAS BEEN DESCRIBED
AS MORE JAIL-LIKE.
WHICH HAS BEEN REFERRED TO AS
KIDS IN CAGES.
AND TED CRUZ SAID, YOU KNOW,
REAL RATHER TAKE THEM TO THE
TIEONA FACILITY BECAUSE IT’S AT
65% CAPACITY KIDS GO IT SLOPE
HUNGRY, THEY SLEEP ON THE FLOOR.
THEY HAVEN’T SEEN SUN LATE IN
SEVEN DAYS AND IT’S FULL OF
COVID.
WHY DID THE WHITE HOUSE AND
THAT’S THE PLACE I’M TALKING
ABOUT RIGHT THERE IN DONNA,
TEXAS.
THOSE ARE THE LEAKED PHOTOS FROM
CONGRESSMAN CUELLAR.
WHY DIDN’T THE WHITE HOUSE TAKE
REPORTERS TO THAT PLACE RATHER
THAN, YOU KNOW, THE PLACE THAT
THEY ESSENTIALLY ARE PUTTING ON
THEIR BROCHURES BECAUSE IT’S RUN
PERFECTLY?
>> BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT
TRANSPARENT.
THEY ARE HIDING THE TRUTH FROM
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
FOR THE SAME REASON THEY WON’T
ADMIT THERE IS A CRISIS.
I MEAN THANK GOD FOR CONGRESSMAN
HENRY CUELLAR WHO GREW UP ON
THAT BORDER LEAKING THEM PHOTOS.
BECAUSE HE TOLD THE TRUTH.
THE SECRETARY TWO DAYS LATER
SAID WE ARE GOING TO SHOW SOME
FILM AND PICTURES.
WE ARE NOT READY YET.
CONCENTRATING OPERATIONS HENRY
CUELLAR LEANINGS PHOTOS AND 24
HOURS LATER SHOWING THEIR
PICTURES SHOWING THE FACILITY
DOCTORED UP AND TAKEN CARE OF.
THEY ARE HIDING THE TRUTH
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE MERE FACT THEY WON’T ADMIT A
CRISIS 5,000 CROSSINGS A DAY
SHOW YOU THEY HAVE NO PROBLEM AT
ALL HIDING THE TRUTH FROM THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND WHAT’S GOING
ON DOWN THERE.
STEVE: THERE ARE 16,000 KIDS IN
FEDERAL CUSTODY THIS MORNING.